foreign
one of the things I've noticed that I do
different than others is this what I
call bias to action like we're not going
to leave a conversation without you
having at least one two or three actions
to take because I think this time spent
together is so expensive
for you for me frankly that if we're
just gonna
think deeply about things come to
answers that are likely very likely to
work
and then not turn them into actions and
do them and me not follow up and
specifically see if you did them but
then just go to another meeting two
weeks from now and start all over a
super expensive time and ideate and but
not have done anything in between to me
it's just like my stomach curls when I
think about that so my coaching is all
about driving towards an action and I
have a system and the system is all
about writing that down and checking to
make sure it got done and that's it and
I find it works with individuals it
works with teams it works with companies
and it's called accountability and it it
can be done in a micromanaging shameful
way or it can be done in a I'd like to
help you succeed way and of course as a
coach
you can stop coaching with me anytime so
it's much easier for me to make it feel
like I'm trying to help you succeed way
if I'm your boss and you're giving you a
paycheck and you're afraid to let go the
paycheck then it can easily feel like
I'm micromanaging you but there is no
difference when I coach someone I become
their manager period end of story and if
by the third meeting they feel more
successful more engaged more empowered
than they know the system works and it's
all written out so you can just copy
paste use with their team members and
then it works with our team members as
well
let's look a little more closely at
accountability because this is one of my
favorite topics
and
I mean the tools can be
Rusty they can be
even mediocre in a lot of cases but if
you use them routinely it's a lot better
than the person as a pristine perfectly
sharpened tool that never gets used
and for me and I've thought and written
about this a lot as it relates to
behavioral modification which is what
we're talking about in many respects
whether that's diet exercise quitting
smoking starting a new Behavior whatever
it might be New Year's resolutions that
accountability Beats
sort of a elaborate planning most of the
time
I would say all the time all the time
great so let me read something and this
is
I believe this is either something
written by you or your team and I'd love
to hear you elaborate on it
if we have to do something that isn't
Fun and we're alone it is painful but if
we're in the presence of another human
then we're usually okay to do that thing
which isn't Fun who that other human is
doesn't matter too much it can be our
child our EA or any other random person
could you give an example of how this
might work
because I found this to pique my
curiosity
so I find that they're generally
personality types that I encounter when
coaching and one big bucket is introvert
versus extrovert and obviously it's a
sliding scale but people generally fall
one side or the other and extroverts
I've known and I'm an extrovert
just feel more comfortable around humans
and there are these solo tests this goes
back to in the beginning you talk about
your anger your frustration around
having to do these administrative tasks
that don't create any value but only you
can do them because you're the only one
you're the investor named Investor
individually so only you can get the K1
and your assistant can't get it because
she's not you and it would a pain in the
ass and so you've got to do it and
you're probably doing it alone and
you're probably going ugh and so I have
things like that as well and plenty of
extroverts have to think there's some
amount of stuff you just got to do and
so what I've noticed is in my own life
and I've recommended this to many people
and they've done it like oh my God
that's amazing
is just having another living breathing
human in the room
creates a sense of Peace enough of a
sense of peace that these tasks no
longer feel so annoying because our body
is no longer so sensitized we're
sensitized extrovertra sensitized when
they're in the alone position but when
they're not alone their bodies just
aren't asensitized and so these tasks
become less onerous and I've literally
hired people to sit in my office with me
on a couch reading a book while I do
administrative tasks and it works and
I've recommended this to dozens of
people and they now do it and it works
for them